the outfit thing is actually because my
content team that wanted to make content
about it because they're like dude
you're Maniac with this like
when they walked in for like almost a
year and a half there was stacks of shoe
boxes and I would wear different shoes
for an hour a day a week and they kind
of graduated to like if they're good
enough or I can walk around the
apartment I'll walk around for their day
if I can walk around with him for a week
and I still like them and most of them
never got there so I have a few
finalists that got to that point but
like I think I just like obsess about
making things better if there's a good
enough company that does no strips like
I'm going to iterate the product a bunch
of times until I think it's absolutely
Untouchable and then I'll say this is
the one I use and I can say that with
confidence because I I did the work on
it